while we're dusting off old quotes
tonight here's another money is the life
but lifeblood of politics and that leads
us to correspondent Peter Ducey's look
at where the two parties stand
financially as we head into the summer
campaign season as Democrats try to
mount a blue wave some Republican
strategists are dealing with a red alert
that's because committees dedicated to
helping Democrats flip control of the
House and Senate have now out raised
Republican committees dedicated to
keeping control and even though there
are fewer Democratic Senate hopefuls
their campaigns are raking in more than
Republicans same story in House races
where the National Republican
Congressional Committee is emailing
supporters to donate quote to show Nancy
Pelosi we won't go down without a fight
but the GOP knows it's a long time till
November money's like horseshoes and
hand-grenades you don't need to have the
most you just got to be close and that
deficit that we have in cash on hand
it's going to be a race because the
d-triple-c spending three million
dollars at least in California in
advance the primary just to get a single
Democrat through into the general a
bright spot for the right the RNC has
raised almost double the DNC's total
that's deficit the DNC dismisses the RNC
is always out raised our party and so
when we think about the opportunities
that exist
it's about being clear how do we find
more ways to mobilize itself the
Republicans out raises two to one in
2005-2006 and yet we still took back the
house outside money is also pouring into
these midterms from the right with the
congressional leadership fund pledging
forty eight million dollars worth of ads
in the general election and from the
left with liberal billionaire Tom stires
next gen America pumping in thirty
million dollars stires spent last year
campaigning to remove President Trump
from office
in Congress once impeach the president
for far less the ads have evolved to
become more midterm specifics but
analysts believe steyr is buying just to
have one of his spots pop up on TV at
the White House mar-a-lago or wherever
else the president may be tuned in the
thing that he wants the most in the
whole world is for Donald Trump to tweet
at him and make him Tom Steyer the voice
and the vision of the Opposition right
around the same time the Democrats took
the lead and money raised Republicans
started erasing the Democratic lead in
voter preference and now the GOP is
within the margin of error in gold
standard polls like our Peter Doocy
following the money Peter thanks a lot